Let's pray together over day 37, Holiness and the
Emotions.
Father, thank you for the gift of emotions.
We are truly thankful. They sometimes are
frustrating, but they're also wonderful.
And so we pray that you would accept our gratitude for making
us feel.
You feel, and you made us like you, and we thank you for that.
I praise you for revealing yourself as a God who is
truly happy and joyful. We pray, Lord, that you would help us
to find our happiness in our holiness, like
you are happy in your holiness. We pray, Lord, that you would
help us not to be a victim of our emotions, that
they would not just happen to us, but that they would happen
through us. We pray, Lord, that you would help us to, like the
songwriter said, not trust the sweetest frame, but wholly
lean on Jesus' name. Lord, don't let us lean
into and depend upon our emotions to carry
us along the way, but help us to rest in Jesus.
Would you give us, Lord, the ability to fully trust in you and to
have the joy of the Lord that
results from a right spiritual
focus in our minds and our wills. Would you help us, O
God? Give us the grace to do that. Sanctify
our emotions. Lord, sometimes we have been led around
by the nose by our emotional state.
We've gotten up in the morning and felt great and assumed that everything was great
with you, even if it wasn't. Or sometimes we've gotten up and felt
terrible or discouraged, and we've assumed that you had forsaken us or
that we weren't right with you, even when we were.
So, Lord, instead, set us free from depending on and being
led around by our emotional state, and make us instead
confident like Jesus is confident, resting in you
every single moment of every day. We pray in Christ's name.
Let's continue to pray and seek the Lord together.